يلونون انفسهم يوما باللون الابيض ويوما
باللون الاسود
لاحياء تقليد سنويا فريد يشارك فيه الالاف
في شوارع كولومبيا
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده
عادات وشعوب
هنا مهرجان السود والبيت احتفال سنوي يقام
في مدينه باستو جنوب غربي كولومبيا منذ
اكثر من قرن ويمتد بين الثامن والعشرين من
شهر ديسمبر حتى السادس من يناير يطلق عليه
كرنفال الاخوه الانسانيه وهو واحد من اهم
الاحتفالات في كولومبيا وتدور احداثه في
منطقه عرفت بعدم المساواه بين السكان
الاصليين والكولومبيين اصحاب الاصول
الافريقيه لكن هذا الاحتفال يذكرهم بانهم
اخوه مهما تعددت اشكالهم والوانهم واصولهم
[موسيقى]
تلوين الوجوه بالابيض او الاسود طقس مهم
من طقوس المهرجان ويرمز لنبد العنصريه
يبدا المهرجان بمعارك مائيه بين الاف
المشاركين ثم السير بصحبه دمى خشبيه ضخمه
واستعراضات موسيقيه راقصه بالملابس
التقليديه لمختلف السكان
[موسيقى]
المجسمات الضخمه هنا بوجوهها الملونه
والمرعبه احيانا تفسير في الشوارع بصحبه
الموسيقى والرقص وتتطلب هذه المجسمات
الكثير من الوقت والجهد لصناعتها بواسطه
حرفيين متخصصين
[موسيقى]
هذه التقاليد ينظر لها باعتبارها طقوسا
عنصريه لدى بعض الدول لكنها هنا في
كولومبيا حدث منتظر يوحد سكان من شتى
الاعراق والالوان ومصدر فخر متوارث لهم
منذ عقود من الزمن
شاركونا ارائكم هل ترغبون في زياره
كولومبيا لمشاهده هذا الكرنفال للاحتفالي